hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
today we're going to be taking a look at
the top reasons to want the nexus prime
keep in mind this phone doesn't really
exist yet but we're going to take a look
at that list anyway so strictly based on
rumors the first of which we have is
android 4.0 or ice cream sandwich if you
will supposed to be running the latest
version of android and i'm looking
forward to that because i've loved all
the previous nexus devices they're the
first to come up with updates they're
the most developer friendly and
supported they're the most application
supported
they're generally the best of the best
android devices so i love nexus devices
anyway second is the screen this is
supposed to be a samsung build so it's
supposed to have a samsung screen the
samsung galaxy s2 as we already know has
the super amoled plus display
beautiful display gorgeous display i
love it so if this does in fact have a
samoa led display i'd be very pleased
it's also rumored to have a 1280 by 720
resolution which would be really
impressive especially it's supposed to
be a larger panel as well a four and a
half to four point six five inch screen
not so confident about that being
packable friendly but we'll see how that
works out and that brings me to battery
life low led displays have always had
phenomenal battery life the galaxy s the
galaxy s2 even things like the zune hd
just have great battery life because of
how oled technology works i might be
doing a video about that later but i
don't know yet but like i said great
battery life and this is also rumored to
have a very large battery something
along the lines of 1650 plus milliamp
hours so great battery life on a great
phone and next on the list is power
power this device is rumored to have
either a next generation dual core 1.2
gigahertz or 1.5 gigahertz processor i
don't really think it's going to have
quad core that might be saved for the
tablet world right now but still it
looks very impressive it's going to be
fast and we love fast phones have you
seen vanilla android on the g2x that is
a really fast device so stock ice cream
sandwich on the nexus prime should just
be slick as hell and next is 4g lte now
nexus and google have been very very
friendly with sprint lately but this may
actually come to verizon first please
verizon please do not screw this up they
already screwed up the samsung galaxy s2
they can't screw up the nexus prime so
prime camera a prime battery life a
prime os a prime display
a nexus prime there you go thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys later
peace
i want this phone so bad
[Music]
you